should we start now sme
yes please thank you okay
so hello everyone uh welcome to invite
us
i am hasan sawadi
i will be hosting the talk today
uh today is a special day
because uh
we are joined by rachel tasman
uh
and she will talk to us today about how
to build our first
chatbot in python
uh
let's hear that when as you might
already know richard tatman is a
a senior developer advocate at vassa
where she has this amazing mission of
helping developers
to use open source tools and
to build
some interesting conversational ai
projects
before that she worked at kaggle and
she did a phd in linguistics
uh
and yeah with commercial and thank you
for accepting our invitation uh we are
happy to have you
with us today
uh thank you for inviting me
but before that uh let me just uh
give me uh give you a brief introduction
about our community
so as you might already know there are a
lot of uh by data chapters and we are
basically basically one of them
and here's our team
so i am hassan and i have with me today
uh
behind the scene yes i mean
shada afnan and abdullah
and of course we didn't forget our
sponsors so thank you
nonfocus and mozan for supporting us
and if you want to learn
more about our community please visit
our website by datajitter.com
or also you can have a look over our
twitter account
uh
and yeah i think that's it basically
from my side
i would like
to say and enco or encourage you to
if you have any questions uh during the
talk uh you can
you know please leave it in the chat
red trouble will
uh answer it even uh either during the
the talk of
after uh
we might have a q a session at the end
of this talk
uh and yeah uh now i can say it
afterwards use virtual you can
take it from here uh thank you very much
great thank you
share my screen second slides up
let me stop
sharing there we go
uh hopefully you can see what i can see
which is my slides
uh so i'm gonna start with just a little
bit of a
uh theoretical introduction to what is
raza um
what sort of systems does it make sense
to build with it so
roslich is the company our open source
framework is rasa open source um and
then we have uh free but not open source
software to
evaluate chat bots since they're in
production and then we also have an
enterprise version of it which is how we
make money so
very brief introduction to raza
um so i'm just going to talk about what
you can do with rasa a super brief
history of nlp
um and then a little bit about some of
the methods we use um so state machines
versus neural methods which i'm sure
y'all have have heard about uh the deep
learning um and then some some thoughts
on evaluation and then we'll do some
live coding together and we'll make a
simple assistant
so the focus of raza is on this specific
domain called task-oriented
systems
and what that means is
the task is something that the user
wants to accomplish and that you want to
help the user accomplish
and they're going to do that by talking
to an automated system in a two-way
conversation um so i guess you could
contrast this with something like a
task-oriented
gui which is not something that people
say but
that would be the
visual equivalent
raza is built specifically for that type
of task uh if you want to do something
like open domain so when your person who
is using the assistant can ask about
literally anything and get a response
that seems you know coherent um we don't
do that you could technically i guess
but it would be uh very difficult so i
probably wouldn't recommend doing that
with raza
um so we're a framework um we're open
source so you can really customize
things to work in your
particular
domain or i imagine for this particular
group language
and the most important thing in building
a ros assistant
that is different from other systems
where you might like have some
pre-trained modules you're using is that
you provide the examples that your
system learns from um so that includes
uh for intents trying to say okay the
person who's using the assistant said
this how do i um classify that into a
a class that lets me make a further
decision right so i might have an intent
that's something like greet and i'll
provide examples of all the different
ways uh some of the different ways that
i think people might say hello to my
assistant
and then i say okay
so i'm good at identifying these classes
of things that people might say now how
do i want my conversations to go
so you'll use something called stories
to do this and this is a pattern of
conversation flow
i'll talk about this in a little bit
um
is built to be highly customizable again
we're open source uh
yes uh so you can also um you know fork
it and maintain your own branch i mean i
wouldn't again i would not know that i'd
recommend that uh we move pretty quickly
as a development team um but if you're
willing to like stick with
a stable pouring to the fork and do your
own maintenance
have at it
um
and as it says this is a video series
i'm using some slides
it is not a video series uh we're just
gonna finish these slides and go into
some live coding
so super super brief history of nlp nlp
is natural language processing so the
field of using computers to talk
to humans using or understand humans
using
human language rather than computer
language
so way back in the 50s and 80s
the focus was really on symbolic
rule-based systems um so everything was
written as a rule a lot more linguists
were employed well i don't know about
that in raw numbers but as a percentage
more of the people working in nlp were
were linguists i'm trained in
linguistics some were handwriting these
rules
uh and then in the 90s through the 2000s
roughly um people started counting
things instead
and this is the point at which you might
have heard
what's his face sorry it's quite early
for me so if i'm a little bit out of
sorts uh
that would be part of it um
every time i fire a linguist my system
performance goes up so that was part of
this general era slash thinking which is
that
we can use statistical methods and
correlations and count things like words
and engrams and characters and use that
as our basis rather than rules
um and starting in the 2010s we started
to use neural methods which i would say
are sort of an extension of the
statistical methods but instead of
statistical modeling we now had enough
compute that deep learning was a thing
that could happen and i'm not going to
go too too in depth about deep learning
i'm assuming again most of you all have
at least heard of it have sort of a good
general understanding of how how that
works
um so things like embeddings and
recurrent neural networks um
and when i was in grad school the really
exciting architecture was bi-directional
lstm with attention which is the flavor
of recurrent neural network and then in
2017 and forward um we got into
transformers which is another class of
neural methods so i would say from
statistical methods onwards we're just
sort of narrowing approaches um rather
than
um
completely changing paradigms as we did
with the rule-based systems
uh so transformers it's a very specific
type of model it was designed originally
for sequence to sequence modeling so
there's an encoder and a decoder
and
basically instead of going over sequence
to learn it as you would with your
current neural network you look at
everything in the sequence and you have
multiple layers of that looking at
everything in the sequence
which is you know
today probably the architecture that
people use
most
commonly when they're looking for new
architectures but
we never like dropped any of the older
things right there's still people using
statistical methods so still people
using you know um
bi-directional lstm with attention just
as an example and there's still people
using rule-based systems so this is more
that we've added additional approaches
and there's been sort of like a shift in
trends rather than we've immediately
dropped all of the older approaches
i think it's just helpful to like have
some context for where these systems uh
are coming from
uh
so understanding text um
this is the sort of general task of
natural language understanding and all
you hear it a lot
and the idea is that you have raw text
human generated text in and on the other
side it is machine readable so a lot of
times people will call it unstructured
text
which i don't like because all sex says
structure because it's all human
language
but there are multiple ways that you can
do this so you could use rules for
example you could have you know
a big piece of text and uh use a regular
expression to find email addresses or
things that match the formatted female
addresses
and the big benefit of this is that you
don't need pretty much any data for
these approaches you just describe what
it is you're looking for in a good
enough way which is uh not trivial but
and they can also run very fast um
and they can also like they don't need
to train right training time is not a
consideration here
the downside of role-based approaches is
they're not very flexible uh so they're
not very good at handling things they
haven't seen before and that you haven't
thought about occurring before they
occur um
so
you know benefits and drawbacks
um on the neural side
you could do something like using a
transformer based model so we've
developed one called
diet which is a multitask architecture
that does both intent recognition trying
to figure out what's the general class
of the thing the person said and entity
recognition picking out you know
mentions of specific named entities from
the text and extracting them
um
and that model is transformer based
and so the downside of that is that it
requires training examples which means
that you have to create and annotate
those training examples
and the more like the
training examples are to the actual data
that you are seeing in production the
better and if you can get the actual
data that you're going to see in
production and use that that's the best
i will touch on that in a bit
but the benefit of using a neural
approach really sort of machine learning
based approaches is that they're pretty
good at
handling things they haven't seen before
so um they'll make a guess right like
every time they'll make a guess um and
the way that we we can talk a little bit
about this later if anyone has questions
but the way that we
balance rules and machine learning uh is
that we we use a
our dialogue policies
this is all configurable by default um
you're gonna have three dialogue
policies and uh each of the
the guesses from those policies will be
associated with a um
a confidence score and the
the policy that's the most confident
wins right so it's a um
there's a specific name for this type of
architecture it's too early for me to
remember um but basically everybody gets
a try and the person who
the model it's like it's me i'm very
confident that's right that's the one
you go with
um
so ross assistant would use both right
you'd use some rules you'd use some
subneural methods for both the
entity extraction and intent
classification
but the the neural methods are really
the core of the framework and when
you're developing a system this
framework the majority of their work is
coming up with examples and organizing
your classes in a way that makes sense
um so i hinted at this before deciding
what to do next in the conversation so
this is the job of the dialogue policy
um and dialog policies
choose what your assistant does next
given the input that it's had so far
and that doesn't just have to be
responding to the user right it could be
kicking off some
custom code it could be um you know
doing human handoff so sending a message
to like a customer service
representative and being like hey
this person has a question for you
um
so historically this was where the
i don't want to say all of it but like
this was the thing that people thought
about a lot in in dialogue systems
research
um and the
uh
old-timey way
i'll say of doing that is doing it by
rules um so you have
a big tree of all the possible cop
possible paths a conversation can take
uh and as people pick options they move
to the trees so if you've ever played a
video game where you have a dialogue
system where you pick different things
to say and then the character you're
talking to says something and you pick a
different thing to say but then you can
go back to the top if you talk to that
person again and go down the tree a
different path that's an example of a
dialogue trait
it's the traditional approach it works
very well
in cases where it is not important that
your system is flexible right your
system does two things and it does them
extremely well and you know everything
that somebody might want to do um
the downside is they can't hand i should
say handle uh you can't handle
aggressions so if i start down the tree
and i'm like wait but i want to talk
about this thing instead
too bad the system will fail
and also if you've ever worked with a
really large state machine like this for
a really large dialogue tree with us you
you will know it is very difficult to
maintain an extent um
it's a huge pain so we would not
recommend them for more complex systems
and systems where you want your
assistant to really be flexible
neural approaches um so our approach is
a transformer based model again this is
one that we've developed in house and
all these papers are out there and also
some some videos uh if you're interested
in the algorithms in more depth um so
ted is our our transformer
enabled dialogue i think is what that
stands for um and it will pick the next
turn based on the conversation so far
and all the conversations it's been
trained on
uh and the real benefit of
a
transformer based model like this is
that it handles regressions very
naturally so i mentioned that
transformers look at everything right so
if you think about your dialogue history
being up and down like a chat box i
don't know why dialogue history is up
and down but text is right and left or
left to right depending on what you're
writing um
so if you're looking at everything over
the history of a conversation right and
you have that that attention you're not
having a super high
you're not waiting things that are more
recent most highly right if someone
digresses so they're talking about here
and oop they change topic okay i can
sort of guess what to do here based on
the last turn and then they change topic
back again then a transformer model will
look at all of the terms and be like
well these aren't relevant anymore let's
go back up to what we were talking about
here so it's very flexible in that way
and it handles regressions really well
um and
it's nice to use as a user
uh the downside to a neural method is
that it requires training examples um so
patterns of what you want a conversation
to look like and in general the more the
better the closer they are to actual
conversations that someone's had with
your assistant the better
um so
it's
you know
it's can be more work to build initially
than a rule-based system for sure no
question about that um but you end up
with a system that's a lot more flexible
and also a lot more extensible
as long as you don't have training data
that directly contradicts each other um
you can just keep adding training data
so we recommend using both approaches um
rules i would say are useful for things
like
two-turn conversations so um let's say
every time somebody asks if this is a
bot that they're talking to i should say
yes it's a bot right or every time
someone says goodbye i should say
goodbye um so if it's just like if x
happens then y always happens that's a
great place for a rule otherwise
using the the transformer driven policy
and having a lot of training examples
will really help have a flexible robust
assistance
um
so
i think this is the last slide and then
i'll get into the the live coding
it was um
the the benefits of using the sort of
hybrid system um
is that it really lets your users
interact very naturally which
when you start
to have an interfaces based on natural
language there is an assumption that it
will work as well as the other types of
places where people use natural language
which is talking to people so the bar is
high right
um and the benefits of using this hybrid
approach and especially using neural
methods is that it can be
really flexible right every single
conversation that somebody has with your
your assistant might be unique it won't
be most conversations will follow the
same few couple pads
but some won't
is sort of the general way that shakes
out
and it also works better the more data
you have and when i say high quality
data here i mean data that matches the
distribution of the data that your
assistant will see a distribution in
distribution in production and of course
the best way to know that is to look at
your assistant once it's in production
so how do you make sure that
conversations work um one thing i didn't
mention here is by writing tests so
having a test conversation where you
know that this is the pattern that it
should follow and making sure that your
system is doing that
but the other way is once your
assistant's in production manually
reviewing and annotating conversations
so
looking at what happened and trying to
figure out was this a good user
experience how can i change my assistant
to make it better
and then adding that training data into
your assistant and then retraining and
uh redeploying so like um
cid
with a a model sorry i was just like
flipping through um
uh
acronyms and just having a hard time
pulling out the one that i wanted um so
the assumption with the roster assistant
is that it's going to continue to change
over time um
we call it conversation driven
development uh and the the tool that i
mentioned at the beginning raza x is
designed for this process right so it
helps um you know
we're working on being able to identify
the conversations that are going to have
the greatest impact if you look at them
and annotate them um to just sort of
make things a little bit faster um i
don't think that's shipped quite yet uh
but we've definitely talked about it
before
uh
rod says how does raza handle poor
spelling or grammatical errors uh the
way that humans do or that human story
yeah yeah um
yeah that's a great question so
for spelling um
two things a if people keep doing it in
the same way um you can just add it to
your trading data and you'll be fine uh
spelling errors are not random
uh b
the simplest way to handle this is by
using a character level model so this is
a model um where instead of looking at
words or morpheme boundaries you instead
have a sliding window over a set number
of characters um right so if i have you
know if i'm looking for exactly apple
apple um and there's a mis there's a
typo i'm gonna have a hard time if i'm
looking for
the word apple but i'm looking at over
three character spans right app ple pple
ple
ppl ple
oh why did i why am i doing this to
myself it's very hard to do uh in my
head um and you know i i take out one of
the p's uh or take out the l right i'm
still gonna have
app
right and then there's gonna be more
overlap between them um so character
level model will work really well for
that
uh
uh konsta's intent classifier does a
good job with that especially when there
are more training examples yes so the
more training examples the better and uh
the more you sort of um
you know
add data that is representative of what
people are doing the better
um uh
sham says do i need to know deep
learning to start with raza no
in fact i would say the majority of our
developers um are software developers
who have not worked with machine
learning previously um and we try really
hard like if you care obviously you can
tune it away um and really mess with it
to
you know your own ends um but we've
tried really hard to make it usable
without that deep learning knowledge
it's just that we use it and that has
implications for your development
process
uh
uh abdullah says
uh nice to have you here oh thank you uh
you
said when you use both ten rules uh do
you mean stories and roles what if they
overlap each other
right so
that's a great question um i sort of
hinted at this a little bit earlier
um
so rules when a rule is triggered it is
always a hundred percent confident right
so i mentioned that if you know all the
dialogue policies so the rules are
dialogue policy the um
the the ted is a dialogue policy that's
based on the training stories and
there's another sneaky one i didn't
mention which is memoization which
basically if i have seen this pattern in
my conversation training data i'm going
to keep following that pattern um so we
all get a vote uh the memoization policy
if it has seen this pattern before 100
uh that
has really high confidence so that's
likely to win um if a rule is triggered
if the pattern rules like hey this
pattern is happening we have to follow
that um that will come first so rules
will always be the number one thing that
are picked if they apply
and then memoization
and then the ted policy because it's
usually
it's trained on the stories right
um
it's
bounded right like most of the time the
confidence is not going to be one uh and
so that's usually the one that gets
that's picked third
and the the transformer policies are
really better for the things where you
haven't seen this exact thing before in
your training data and people are doing
things a little bit differently so
that's
the answer
there uh if they overlap each other if
they overlap each other and are
contradictory you'll get a warning when
you try to train your model uh so you
can go and fix that
uh
cool
let's do some live coding i'm gonna stop
one sec i've lost
i have lost the uh
the zoom controls
oh there it is okay sorry i was trying
to find uh where the stop sharing was
uh let me get vs code up real quick
and we'll start an assistant
there we go okay
so i already have raza installed this is
the command prompt right and it's in a
conda environment and we have some
walkthroughs on youtube that show you
how to do this um
sorry i'm trying to remember what my
condo environment's called
i think it's called
raza install
it was called roz install good job um
so i'm currently in should be
hope i'm in an empty directory
yep i'm in an empty directory um so i am
going to create a new raza assistant and
um the way that i do that is
raza init so when you um install raza
with pip but also installs um a you know
command lined
tool
so that you can interact with raza in
the command line
and i'm gonna train an initial model as
well and this is gonna take a little bit
so this creates the full directory
structure that you need for your
assistant and also some
uh basic files and i'm just going to let
it
train while i sort of talk about what
these are
endpoints doesn't matter really that's
for more for deployment stuff and
creating endpoints
as you might have guessed credentials
also deployment stuff
config is where you describe
what your
um
basically what sort of like puzzle
pieces you're putting together for for
your nlu um for english you shouldn't
need to mess with this until you know
you have your system up and running um
i'm gonna guess i'm gonna get some
questions about arabic just gonna just
gonna guess that and
oh
i've not built an assistant in arabic
and i don't know how i would be able to
evaluate it if i did because i uh i
don't know the language
um
but this is where you would make your
language specific changes in the
config.yaml
uh let's talk to our assistant really
quick so i can show you what it does and
then we'll get into the
uh
files a bit more
it's loading oh it's on localhost um
sorry if you're on windows there's a
thing with localhost where um
because of the way the
anyway it introduces some additional lag
uh
which is why it'll be a tiny bit slow so
uh right now i'm talking to my assistant
in the shell so i'm going to start by
saying hi to kick off the conversation
uh
hi how are you and this is an assistant
called mood bot so um
i'm going to say that i'm really sad
and it will show me well it's not going
to render in the command line but it
it'll just say bye no
no you're supposed to uh
i'm sad you were supposed to uh show me
a picture of a baby tiger there we go um
so if i say i'm sad uh it should show me
a picture of a baby tiger so something
like this happens right and i was
reviewing data um at a guess this was
not annotated as the correct intent this
intent should be you know mood sad i
think is the name of the intent and
instead it's been detected as bi right
as me saying goodbye and i think it
might be because i included a smiley um
but this one i think was detected
correctly because this is my uh intended
thing uh joel says not enough intense
examples yeah definitely uh could
absolutely extend it
um does that help you
i'm not gonna click on the picture and
go look at it but believe me when i tell
you it's a baby tiger
um
and then uh the assistant just says
great carry on and i can also ask things
that you know other things so like i can
ask are you a bot and it should say it's
not
uh and sure enough it does it says i'm
about powered by rasa uh and then just
obviously just stop
uh so
that's the assistant that uh is created
by uh
by default when you get going so let's
poke around in these files a little bit
and i'll talk about what's in them
uh so endpoints and uh credentials not
super important
uh config so right now the language is
arabic
the language is english and i am not
sure
so this language code here um will
affect some of the spacey components and
i'm not sure what space you support for
arabic is like
uh
oh nice mohammed says uh i tried to
build it for arabic it worked perfectly
fabulously um
good sorry
a little drink of water
good good glad to hear it
um if you did need additional
customization
uh
at some point and i wouldn't really
recommend messing about with this too
much until you have your assistant like
you have all your training data and when
you have you know
about as much training data as you're
willing to add um if you want to get
like a little bit of additional
improvements um that's when i would i
would consider looking at your pipeline
but you shouldn't need to mess with it
too much these are pretty reasonable
defaults
um
and this is this is what's in it and i
can talk about it in a little bit
greater detail but basically these are
the steps that your text is processed
through
um in order to
um
these first ones are the steps that your
text is processed through in order to
get it from that raw text to the machine
learnable readable format
um and these second ones are for um
how your assistant decides what to say
next right so the dialogue policy um the
memoization is the one that's like hey
if i've seen the story before i'm gonna
keep doing it the ted policy is the
machine learning one based one and the
rule policy is for my rules
uh
yeah and again
you don't really need to mess with this
um
if you don't want to but you can right
and then the more important file in the
the top four files is this domain file
um so this is just the raza version it
was built under um this is the list of
intents so these are all the things that
my
assistant knows about uh so that the
user can say to it so greek goodbye
affirm which is like yes uh deny which
is like no uh mood great moon unhappy
and bot challenge uh bot challenge we
recommend you always include this it's
you know
is this this is this a person am i
talking to you about that sort of thing
um because you don't want to you don't
want to lie to people and tell them
they're talking to a human when they're
not um
not in the least because your assistant
probably isn't going to be as good as a
human would be uh and it'll be very
frustrating for users and this was the
mood unhappy it was the one that was not
correctly detected in the little little
sample
and then responses these are all the
things that the assistant can say to the
user so
if you need to
you can
um
you can generate responses i would not
recommend it in general um i would
recommend you know
writing them out like writing out all
the things you want your assistant to
say um
and also think about
the other thing to think about is even
if you've written out the assistant
responses
are there one of those things where
it would
not be good to respond in that way right
so here one example here would be like
utter happy right so this is what our
system's supposed to say if the person
says i'm feeling good um
and we say great carry on and if this
was a response to
um let's say i moved unhappy right and
this was incorrectly detected um
you know that could be a little bit mean
so just the things to think about when
you're writing your assistants uh
so i'm going to say glad to hear you're
doing well carry on um because this way
if someone says i'm so sad uh then this
response makes it a little bit clearer
that
hey um
the there was an issue with the
assistant here and we're not being
intentionally mean to you if that makes
sense sorry a little bit of a
little bit of aggression there but
anyway this is all the things your
assistant can say to your users um
and then just some session config stuff
this is also where you'd have things
uh like slots so slots are variables
that are carried over the course of your
conversation we don't have any here but
we could have like one for let's say um
if we could show a picture of a baby
tiger or a baby bird and we had people
pick which one they wanted then we could
have a slot called picture content i
guess
um so whatever you need you add a new
intent or response or slot or entity so
we're not extracting any entities here
but we could maybe we could extract
moods as entities so
um happy sad angry that sort of thing um
that would also be in here
so that's these files
models you don't really need to worry
about but basically every time you train
your assistant so you can do that using
raza train and the command line it'll
create a new model uh
and um i mean it's a tar so we can't
look at it uh but they'll all be in here
and they'll all be saved by um
by date and time so there will be an
order
um tests so i mentioned that this is one
of the ways you can make sure your
assistant works um so these are stories
that when well actually let's just do it
uh
i have okay
i'll show you what happens when i do
rows of tests uh so i have in here some
stories that i've written uh where the
uh user turns are provided and the
intent so this is you know this is going
to be given to the assistant as if the
user said it
i expect it to be uh
identified with this intent and i expect
the assistant to do this
in the in response to it and so we have
a couple here um and this just makes
sure that your assistant can do what you
want it to do
um
so
i'll wait for this to finish loading and
then we'll go through the results a
little bit so this is how you would
evaluate your assistant um
and
validate that your machine learning is
working the way you expect it to and
that especially if you start adding
intents or changing stories or adding
more stories and retraining
you would expect the the assistant to
continue to be able to pass your tests
um
so
we have
uh
a sorry i'm having a hard time making
this line up exactly we have a confusion
matrix for each of the intents um
and i mean you can't see what they are
here um but the full results are in here
and i believe it should be a nice little
png
emphasis on the little um so we have a
confusion matrix for our intents
we have a histogram for our confidence
predictions so all of our intent
predictions are very confident
this suggests to me probably we should
add more training data which i think is
not not a surprise to us you sort of
want a range of
uh
of confidences
and then confusion matrix for the
entities but we didn't extract any
entities so it's just empty um
and then
none of our stories failed so uh when it
comes time to test your system that's
the way you do that and that's what sim
tests
uh
can i spam nlu across multiple files
yes so that's a great question let's pop
into the last directory well
second to last directory which is this
data directory
so our default way that this is
organized
is that your nlu
dot eml is all of the training data for
all of your intents so here we have an
intent greet and here's all the ways
that we think somebody might say greet
i think we recommend like at least 17 to
20 examples per intent
more is better
and this is the default configuration
with nlu in one file rules in one file
and stories in one file um as long as
it's in the data folder and it's a yaml
file it should be included and we don't
care a whole bunch about what the exact
configuration looks like um
yeah especially is once you get to the
point where your assistant is quite
large and
has a lot of training data you don't
want to like scroll for five minutes to
get to the thing that you want
um so examples of saying goodbye
et cetera
and like deny here could have probably
some more examples as well so let's say
nope or
uh
uh i just has additional ways to say no
make sure i save this and i'm going to
need to retrain my model for any of
these changes to to take effect
somebody's saying they're happy
this one super sad i think is what i
said
um
i'm trying to see if there's anything
here that would make sense for me to uh
have had that maybe this super and super
stoked possibly
um
yeah
uh and then bot challenge uh let me add
some data there
uh
are you a real person
so this is you know um you can do this
by hand um
you can you know import data and format
it correctly it's just a basic camel
uh
can i put lookup examples in a separate
file if i have 10 000 entity examples
yes um so lookup is um i mentioned that
you can use rules
if you don't want to write out regular
expressions that are like exactly match
the string you can have something that's
called a lookup table and yes that
should be able to be in a separate file
as well
and basically it'll just create regular
expressions for each of the things that
you're looking up and then detect them
and extract them
so the other thing i talked about were
stories um this is what these look like
so the happy path is the thing that like
we hope people say
this is the outcome we hope for so we
say hi the user says hi
intent from the user uh the assistant
utters crete from our domain file uh
the user says i'm feeling great the
assistant says
good or
glad to hear you're feeling good i think
because we wrote we wrote this in uh the
utterance um sad path etc so we only
have a couple paths here as people start
to interact with the assistant um what
we can do from rasa x i don't have a ros
x instance running so i'm not gonna do
that right now but would be
adding uh conversations that the
assistant has had with people as
training data right so someone's having
a conversation it gets
doesn't go well um then you would um
you know correct it so it does go the
way that you sort of want it to go in
the future and then add that to your
training data and retrain
and then the final thing
i guess i made a change there i don't
know where that happened
is uh
this rules um
file and again these are this is sort of
by convention these folders do not have
to be in this way
uh
so here we have a simple rule every time
somebody says goodbye we said goodbye
back every time someone says something
that's detected as a bot challenge we
say i'm a bot um
i believe in two point current version
uh rules can only be one turn and also
only use them for one turn you don't
wanna have really complex rules it
believe me when i say that it gets
rough to maintain very very quickly
um so that's in the data file and again
you can you can rejigger these however
you like um this is just sort of our our
default recommended
uh
i'd also say should i repeat an intent
in all stories if it has many paths
yes um
two things i'm thinking about there so
um
one
when we train from stories
uh
to do when we train from stories
um it sort of happens under the hood but
we don't necessarily train just like
from first to last uh instead we sort of
take chunks of those stories
and and move them around a little bit um
just to make it
easier for us to to capture things that
are going well so
a story doesn't have to be a full
conversation from start to end we can
handle it if it's not
the other thing that you can use is
checkpoints so if you have sort of like
a branch
use these sparingly but um if like every
conversation is going to have a first
half that's the same but a second half
that's different right or you have like
three possible ways the first half can
go and two possible ways the second half
can go um what you can do is you can
create a checkpoint
this is all in the docs i'm only focused
on one window now so i don't think i can
show you very easily um but
that's like okay get to here
checkpoint look for all the other places
where this checkpoint occurs and then
look for those stories um again if you
ever use that you have rebuilt a state
machine which we don't recommend um yeah
hope that helps
consist
preserve the context
i
let me know if that didn't if you still
have a question on that hopefully that
was helpful
um
yeah so that's the training data and the
way that ah fabulous um so that's the
training data and the way that that is
handled and then the final thing
is this actions file
um
so i mentioned that one of the things
that your assistants can do
um it can yes of course um respond using
text and it's the easiest thing to do
we've tried to make that really
streamlined
you can also trigger code so
um
the way this would work is you'd have
from an architecture level um your
assistant will run on a server um
and then you have a separate server
running that it will make calls to via
our api it's all open source you can
check out uh the more details on the api
if you like in our docs which is
raza.com i believe i should know that
off the top yeah it's
it's directly in front of me it's right
here
um
yeah um so you can also have a separate
server running with uh code and
why would there not be code on the
server you can also have a second server
running and make calls to that second
server from your rasa assistant um by
default we assume you're going to use
python we have a
pretty robust python sdk um
one of our engineers has worked on a go
sdk as well so if you're a go person
that might be an option for you um but
you can have pretty much any arbitrary
code you want triggered from within the
assistant um so here we just have like a
little example uh
example
action uh i think it just like yeah it
just returns some text that says action
hello world um so you can make
utterances from within these actions you
can have your bot do something you can
of course you know integrate with other
apis trigger something externally i get
a lot of questions about databases and
database integrations usually you're
gonna have to use um some sort of action
file some sort of um
your action server will have to handle
that integration um
we do some integrations but it's mostly
to keep the history of the conversation
um and it's not really designed for you
know
you know customer lookup or something
like that
uh can i deploy a razzabot in streamlit
yeah so uh
vincent remember damn who's another
person on the devil team has uh i'm
gonna pull up the
link in another window uh has a utility
he made called rosalit um
which is more about exploring the model
but might be a good place for you to
start
um
yeah
i don't know that i've seen somebody
deploy like a full assistant in
streamlit
yeah usually so the
we also have a lot of integrations that
i haven't really talked about here um
but thinking about the integration
requests that we get most often a lot of
people use facebook messenger uh a lot
of people use microsoft teams
um a lot of people use um
like a little react widget um on the on
the bottom of their website and then
they integrate with that
so i have a django tutorial for using
web chat is one of the the widgets it's
an open source widget for uh for react
for
um
for raza that
we don't maintain but one of our
community members do um and also we
we have heard the community's feedback
that they would like a rasa maintained
uh
web chat interface and that is something
we know about so thank you for the
feedback from the community
um i make no promises but we know about
it um
yeah
so that is all of the um
that's basically like everything that's
in the
uh
you know
guts i guess
all the stuff that's inside a rasa
assistant um
if you want to um
really get down to brass tacks and start
modifying the machine learning bits um
then the first thing to do would be to
no
yes the first thing to do would be to
mess with uh config um you can also we
are built on tensorflow
um so you can also add uh
tensorflow parameters um either for like
specific components or project wide so
if you want to set a seed or something
like that so for for additional
reproducibility you can do that um
yeah and the this pipeline configuration
is very um
very flexible so this is sort of like
our recommended thing um but like you
don't have to use a diet classifier if
you don't want right you can use a
different one
we also have a pretty good integration
with hugging face and a lot of their
language model stuff so if you wanted to
use a hugging face model um you would
you know
it's several steps to get there
and i would recommend thinking about the
size of your container because any model
that you include in your pipeline is
going to need to be contained within
your container for deployment um
but if that works for you then that's
another thing that you can do to
modify and customize your your pipeline
and your uh
yeah usually people want to want to
modify the nlu pipeline you can't you
can absolutely modify the policies um
i it's rarer for me to see people want
to
to
change the
or or really customize the dialogue
policies but you definitely can so
yeah
so i think i'll leave the uh this code
up in case anybody has any questions um
if you're looking for the code in this
assistant oh actually one sec let's
yeah
uh let's just really quickly retrain our
assistant so you can see what that looks
like so we've made some changes
i'm going to
ah being some power shell
there we go
i'm going to retrain our assistant
uh
sorry i've been having problems with
powershell and uh python specifically
there's some version issues
uh
yeah and then when we talk with our
assistant we should see um
for example a slightly different
response if we say um
that we're feeling sad
or feeling happy
uh
pardon saudi says you have to write
different answers slash questions in
different ways
so
if you're asking do you do you want to
include a lot of paraphrasing in your
intents yes absolutely
um
for if you're asking about how your
assistant responds um you do have this
is sort of the the responses here are
um sort of the simplest way but there
are a lot of ways to customize your
responses so
probably the
simplest way is to include a slot so
right now i don't have any slots but if
i had a slot called name that i was
storing my user's name in
i could include it in my responses like
this um
i could
uh
have
a random selection between multiple
responses by saying something like
right so if i have two um
two texts under a single utterance it'll
be randomly chosen between um when when
it's triggered
um
you can
also have uh channel specific
uh responses so i can have like show
this response on slack and this response
on microsoft teams for example
um
yes if you
if you want to do like full natural
language generation and
that's going to be a little bit more
involved but there's quite a bit of
flexibility in how your responses are
uh how do i get a benefit of a word
inventing model that's a great question
so uh
you're going to want it as a component a
custom component so there's a little bit
of fuzzing you're going to need to do
wow depending on what it looks like
there might be a little bit of fuzzing
you need to do to get it in the right
format uh and then you would once it's
you know
in the right place in your files and in
the right format you would just add it
to your pipeline as like you know
obviously this is all commented out um
you would need to uncomment it out
so once it's all set up you just add it
to your pipeline by adding the name in
there and then these do happen in order
so you'd want to probably put it
probably
actually one up probably before the
count vector featurizer um
yeah
so that's how you do that
yeah it should
hopefully it's pretty extensible
hopefully it's pretty easy to use um
i will say we have
we do
our like i mentioned our development
cycle is pretty fast um so we do tend to
have a lot of minor version updates and
i'd recommend you know updating when you
get the chance um and we have a major
version update on the way as well so
just fyi
uh
yeah okay so our model's been retrained
and let's talk to it so we're gonna do
that using raza well actually first of
all you can see all of the um the
commands for the command line utility
with help um as you would i don't know
maybe you wouldn't expect it uh that's
what i'd expect i don't know that your
expectations are the same as mine
uh and then if i want to talk to my
assistant michelle i can do like so rasa
shell uh and if i want
more information than i will probably
need i can add this debug tag to really
see what's happening
sort of down in there
as you can see it creates a lot of
terminal spam
[Music]
loading the model
uh
the lock store i'm just gonna mention
things that i see them so the lock store
um is what
um
is triggered when your assistant is
waiting for your your user to say
something so it's not just doing a bunch
of stuff if that makes sense all right
so let's try
this
which should be correctly identified as
uh
being sad this time let's see although i
made a typo so we'll see what happened
all right let's go all the way back up
to where we said something uh and then
we can look through the debug log really
quick
okay so it was locked um
tracker is the history of everything
that's happened in the conversation so
that's stored by default um
[Music]
uh
slot values aren't set because i don't
have any slots uh
response selector is not trained because
i don't have a response selector that is
a specific thing that we're not using
right now
okay so our uh
intent
was identified as deny so our assistants
thought that we said no again i made a
typo here um and the confidence here is
pretty low so confidence is a value
between 0 and 1 so
0.57 is is pretty low as you saw in our
test the confidence for the those turns
were all a hundred percent um
so because the intent was uh
identified uh incorrectly
we have never told our assistant what to
do if somebody just says no so it
doesn't know what to do um ted predicted
that we should say goodbye so this is
our transformer-based policy
um
no rules apply so no none of the rules
were triggered
uh
and
uh the next action was utter goodbye
right so this was something that our
assistant had seen before because there
was an error in the nlu
but it still did something right um
anyway so that's
obviously there's a lot of other stuff
uh happening here
uh
hassan says in some applications i may
want to integrate a question answering
system to my chatbot so it would be able
to answer some domain specific questions
how should i do this integration
good question um
stop
this does slash backwards sure is
no it wasn't okay good
um yeah that's a great question so
it depends on
how your question answering system is
configured i would probably if it's
already built um do an action so when i
have
uh
i might even do it as
so i guess the question is are people
going to just answer ask questions in
the course of the um
uh
are people just going to ask questions
in the course of the conversation you
want to use the question answering
system to answer them because if yes
then i would have an intent that's like
i've detected that someone's asking a
question that my question answering
system can handle um
and from there i would trigger an action
and then pass that text over and do
whatever you need to with it
otherwise
you can also use something called faqs
so
an faq
is where you have a set of questions
and um if you detect generally that
something's in that set of questions um
it will it's a set of questions intense
right sort of like a set of intents um
this is what the response selector is by
the way
um
it will pop down into a new model for
intent classification that's choosing
between
the the types of faqs or response
selectors that you have in there
so if you just need a way to answer a
lot of questions and you don't want to
provide a bunch of um
a bunch of stories basically if you are
using an faq one of those intents is uh
identified you will have an utterance
that's like hey when
you know an utterance that by its name
uh rasa will know okay this intent was
identified i immediately do this and i
don't need to add a billion rules excuse
me a billion rules or stories to make it
work um so it automates the process a
little bit uh
uh
yeah but if you already have a system
i'd use in action
that would help
uh muhammad says how do i avoid start
when i deploy my raza on
telegram
yeah so the slash start
is a command that you would silently
send to
um your raza assistant um
to have it start the conversation
without the user having to say anything
to start
i
mean i don't use telegram um so i'm not
super familiar with it but if you can
have like a static first turn that's
like
uh or even like instruction when
somebody start launches the assistant
where it's like hey
ask a question or something so they know
what to do
um
then that might work yeah i think it's
going to really depend on telegram and
i'm not that familiar with the platform
unfortunately
i hope it helps
uh
any other questions
yeah i think uh this brings us to the
end of the meet uh thank you so much
richard uh
for
this wonderful
talk and for this live coding session
and for answering all of the
participants questions
uh
thank you all for joining and
see you soon we're out and also let's
try to
have you again in the future
uh and yeah thank you all for joining
and yeah see you soon
and have a nice day
bye bye
thank you rachel thank you so much
bye everyone